let's see if we can pick back up where
we left off now you're gonna buy that
monitor we finish in place you research
he could be doing what I'm about to do
but you'll be able to do it to other
people ten times where do we start with
the clinic's topic okay we started with
the idea of eccentricity right and then
everything that we've done so far is
about exploring that what happens when
you change it okay so let's start from
the lowest time now it's I wouldn't make
you right circle hopefully now you're
associated you here whenever you see
that you're like what kind of an
equation does it have what's the
standard form for instance there's the
unit zone no problems okay now as we
extend up a little bit if we go from
naught to 1 but can you get an ellipse
and the standard form for the equation
of ellipse is x squared 1 squared plus
that's fine okay now so far both they're
all centered on the origin worried me
again what did they control
yeah so they control the axis right and
there compressions to each other of
course if we wanted to we could swap
them and you get some girl just taller
rather than white above off all right
then you hit this boundary point and you
get a parabola okay so what's the
standard form of a parabola now that
strictly speaking as we continued on
probably a better comparison would be
this guy because everything we did
looking at in sideways yeah but it's
still a problem doesn't matter now I
lost been progress suppose that we
developed this we looked at we tried to
draw it and we got this shape out okay
now we gave you a specific one right I
think it has like I don't know four and
twelve it was some numbers like that
okay
but generally speaking what's the form
of this equation
still that okay that's what's different
okay good now you told me very very very
beautiful what these were for an ellipse
okay
but those features semi-major axis say
minor axis
they don't exist for hyperbola because
there's a lot of close the shape right
so my question to you is what are these
things obviously there's something
important sort of intuition detects that
it has something to do with the
proportions of the hyperbola just like
this has to do with the proportions of
the ellipse the question is what okay so
what I'm gonna ask you to do is go back
to your drawing of that specific one I
gave you
now what do these numbers signify where
would they belong you already know the
fact that it's attached to X so
something attached to Y tell you
something my question is what exactly is
it what is it reflexive now I'm gonna
ask you to walk through last time I
heard your hand through this okay I
asked you to get these and you remember
how we got to that conclusion that they
were the semi-major and the semi-minor
axes we generalize this thing we bought
this relationship remember this B
squared is equal to a squared outside
off
but is where we got that and that's
really useful because now you can go
from an equation if you can get all of
the bits and pieces out of it that's
really useful now I want you to do the
same thing but for this guy okay
we started off with focus and directrix
and then you've got this well if I gave
you a different code you now go ahead
and work out where the foci and director
C's are and what its eccentricity is
could you do it right now probably right
now the answer is no unless you're
really crazy working good but once you
try and go back think that if you've got
the nuts there think back to what we did
with this we've played some geometric
tricks we drew some stuff we thought
about the general case we had to look at
lines what they added up to and so on I
want you to try and do what you do here
here have a think about this this guy
has a special relationship to the
hepatoma but not in the way that you'd
expect okay I want you to see what
relationship this has to this and then I
find out where we're trying to head two
years if you would again and create a
hyperbola right can you give me all of
its features out of it can you tell me
where the focus is what the directrix is
are what the eccentricities
so all works you think that way usually
but I'll give you guys a minute okay
so but this is uninteresting there's so
many of you or so few of you rather
stuck your hands up to see how much
progress you are making because the way
you go about this and the results you
get from almost identical like down to
the meta from what we did with ellipse
okay so as result start seeing being
familiar that's because they are alright
so here's my diagram right now you'll
learn is what am I done here I've set up
almost exactly the same two equations
I've set up with the ellipse right do
you remember them this is a matter of
the definition like the locus definition
of what the hyperbola is okay so you've
got this ratio sorry distance of from
your point to the focus versus the
distance to the directrix and that ratio
is 8 right so I've picked that out just
for the two points a and B and though
they are my ratios okay now do you
remember what we did with those
equations last time we did two things
firstly we added them and then we
subtracted them and then we saw clearly
useful stuff out of them from that okay
so let's give it a go what happens if we
add this do what do you get on the
left-hand side
be ok now the question for you is how do
we combine these into something
meaningful
ok now the S Plus a ball okay you read
the text and that's what they peek at
what distance not X this these things
here that's 1 this distance here so I'm
adding them ok now don't forget where am
I trying to head to in case you're
picking em up I'm trying to get the
focus I'm gonna try and get the
directions the exact same [ __ ] comes
quite a bit later to remember okay
because we're working in terms of
eccentricity
so we shouldn't expect to be able to get
something right so these two let's have
a look what do they relate to must write
well because they're both defined by s
they should tell us something about the
distance to the focus shouldn't they
that's nothing to do with the directrix
which is n okay so therefore when you
add these two green links
together they should give us something
close to something that's related to the
focus right the focus is here now if I
were to find out the coordinates of the
focus for this particular diagram okay
what would its coordinates be lesser
these what's the y-coordinate because
it's on the axis now what's the
x-coordinate some number right it's
symmetrical centered on the origin
we're gonna get in terms of what I have
here that looks to me like you know
suppose this this coordinate was five
suppose okay tell me what would this
distance been fire would then if this
was three what would this distance be so
the coordinate comes from this distance
see that because the distance from the
origin right so you could say it's OS or
their daddy is zero okay now these two
lakes are related to PO s that distance
there can you see it how are we gonna
chop and change to make it obvious
would you chop up you can move around
the short distance or you can chop up
the longer distance and rearrange that I
unthinking you think back to your lips
how we did it personally I would take OB
look at OB see that distance that
distance what's the relationship between
the word be distance and the Oh Agis is
the same it's all this symmetry here
right so I can move this sky Irvine yeah
right now when I add the mark what is a
space it's doubled that distance right
two times the distance are the figures
from Georgia
now what about this M a and B see
come on help out with the first one can
you see it it's going to be well it's
just that whole distance right but hold
on a second we know what this distance
is don't we because I call this capital
a but I actually know where it is
because I have the equation of the
hyperbola right what what are the
coordinates of capital a you'd say
what's on the axis so you say y equals
zero so that means an x squared on a
squared minus zero is equal to one so
you've got X being fossil by this a
right so here's one that's plus a and
that's minus a so what's the difference
between plus a and minus name it's to a
there's an either x - hey okay so choose
cancel so OS is equal to isn't it tell
me that's familiar okay that's that
distance there so if I cannot fill that
in that tells me the coordinates of the
focus are a comma zero which shouldn't
surprise us because all of these
equations are exactly the same as the
ones we did for the ellipse like like
the way they're exactly the same okay so
therefore we do a bit of a shortcut if
I'm trying to work out where the
directress C's are going to be they were
being in the corners then equation x
equals plus or minus something could you
make an educated guess we'll see crating
literacies
Hey